well some breaking news now and the
prime minister won't be forced out of
downey street early at least by a vote
in the house of commons
the eyes to the right were 349
the nose to the left were 238
so the eyes have it the eyes have it
yes mps in the last few moments voted
that they did have confidence in the
government in a vote it called for if
they'd voted against there would likely
have had to be a general election well
let's go to our chief political
correspondent john craig who's in
westminster tonight so a comfortable win
for the government john as the
conservative leadership contest whittles
contenders again to the final two by
midweek two more rounds yes tuesday and
wednesday uh you heard boris johnson
there talking about a majority of 80
well that majority just now was 111. um
if he if he'd lost the price the queen
might have said actually let's get
another tory leader to see if they can
form a a government rather than have a
general election but we really are into
a battle for second place now
rishi sunak has had a very good day
because he's put on 14 votes earlier in
the day
his supporters were suggesting he
probably wouldn't pick up that many new
votes today because it was sweller
bartherman the brexiteer who dropped out
at the end of last week so he's done
well the other winner from tonight's
vote is uh kemi baideneck badenock uh
who's put on
at nine she's up to 58 and really is
starting to breathe down liz truss's
neck liz truss
only put on 764 up to 71 and there's a
real battle now for tom tougenhart's
votes he's dropped out tonight now
tonight rishi sunak liz trust and penny
morden have issued really flattering
statements about mr tugenhart as they
hope to hoover up his votes in the next
round of voting tomorrow
but kenny
badenock her supporters are claiming uh
is the one who's got the momentum now
the surge one of her supporters ben
bradley was telling me a short time ago
she is the insurgent here so she's the
one to watch tomorrow see if she can
cause an upset and some tories are also
saying tonight that the tory party now
looks set to elect either its third
woman leader and prime minister or its
first ethnic minority leader big
contrast with the labour party